you uh you said that you were hanging
out with CM Punk quite a bit yes at
Comic-Con uh what was something that you
learned from Punk because he's my
all-time favorite I love Punk just stand
on what you believe and and don't be a
pushover and I admired that because
coming into the business and being new
you know a lot of people it's like you
have to almost shrink yourself a little
bit yeah and I know who I am again I
live several lives I've lived real life
and just because I didn't want to do
this all my life or because I didn't put
in the time
I I refuse to let anybody look at me
less than and I refuse for anybody to
treat me anything different because
outside of these lines I'm a human
freaking being and you're not going to
treat me like anything else so
um I'm not saying that anyone treated me
any type of way I'm just saying in
wrestling you hear about that yeah of
course of course especially on the
Indies and I I'm not familiar with the
Indies at all but I'm not going to be
walked over and I refuse for you to to
because I'm Jay Cargill and outside of
these lines I'm Jay Cargill so I'm not
going to let you address me anything
less so the fact that he told me to
stand on what I believe and don't be a
pushover that stuck with me he's a great
guy how crazy was backstage the night
that punk did that press conference with
Tony Khan sitting next to him and [ __ ]
hit the fan and it was like I was like
oh my God this is amazing I have no idea
so I wasn't there I had already left the
stadium I had already left um right
after my match I left I was like all
right like I'm out guys and so I heard
about it just like the rest of the world
at the same time yeah it was pretty
shocking um and I saw that looked at
Tony Khan gave him like
yeah yeah but I mean I don't know for my
opinion Punk's a great guy he's been
nothing but nice to the women's locker
room he talks to me um tells me his
experience again at Comic-Con you know
we got really close because he was my my
tag mate in the interviews and I learned
so much from him and so much knowledge
in the industry and again he's you know
been in two different companies and of
course he's he can do whatever the hell
he wants to do so um he doesn't need it
right he does it because he loves it and
that to me speaks speaks to me because I
don't need it I do it because I love it
and I appreciate people like that